the raiders have gotten some heat and
some compliments following a tweet they
sent out yesterday on the conviction of
derek chauvin
rob futrell joins us now with some new
developments today ron
yeah kirsten today george floyd's
brother philanese
gave his thoughts on the raiders tweet
now we're going to take a moment here
to include some context often in short
social media posts
it's hard to provide context so the
tweet was first sent out by the raiders
yesterday afternoon
shortly after the verdict was read it
said simply i can breathe
a reference to george floyd's pleading
20 times
that he could not breathe with the
officers at the scene now today
fellainis floyd told
tmz that he is not offended by the
raiders tweet
and he is not demanding they take it
down raiders owner mark davis
said he approved of the tweet and it was
inspired by the words
of george floyd's brother today
we are able to breathe again because
justice for jaws
means freedom for all well a couple of
the responses to the raiders tweet one
says simply
why did you do that another says i can
delete this
mark davis says he understands the
reaction is 99
negative and he gets that the tweet is
still